Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! Thank you everybody
that submitted questions on my Robb Stark
video. Lot of questions about what's going
on with his will. What the Stark line of succession
might be, especially with what's happening
with Sansa and the Boltons right now. There
will be some interesting questions for the
short answer when it comes back because technically
Ramsey Bolton did consummate the marriage
with Sansa and she's on the run with Rick
right now until someone with a more legitimate
claim comes along they buy rights do hold
the North nothing you be able to convince
the actual citizens of the north of that that
undermines the UN Joffrey almost got ripped
limb from limb by the mob and King's Landing
just because you have a legal claim to something
does not mean the citizens will supported
especially if you're super unpopular which
is kinda what the Bolton's are right now on
the north on the questions of your ego careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen all the way
through season five yet on the TV show stereo
Jon shark asks will this letter somehow provide
protection for Sansone who is now on the run
if the northern Lords recognize Jon snows
the air Sansone but in a way inherent protection
from the Bolton's right will I don't think
that Sansa would would need any kind of official
letter or anything to provide any Protection
and then just for those that he's talking
about that the will Robb Starks will like
the letters that he sent out I think that
she be fine going to any of the other northern
Lords I don't is a unanimously like every
single person from every house in the North
completely 100% his house stark over house
Bolton there were over 45 houses in the North
so their priorities like water to the be too
afraid to help her but for the most part if
she were to say to go to like the Glover's
and Deepwood Mott or go to the last hearth
than in try and stay with the numbers they
would they would totally help her no matter
what the of that situation is actually be
wreak that would be in trouble because most
of the greater Lords would probably know what
he looks like and know what he did the thing
is is like the North is a big place so there
might be some people in some places that have
never seen Sansa start before but for the
most part like the greater houses have all
probably seen her at some point next question
Salem asks if Jon Snow lives in statuses that
do you think that Jon is his or a high the
way I like to think of it I don't know which
interpretation the show is actually going
to go with but I think of his or her high
is being more of a metaphor like not an actual
person just the title that gets given to someone
at any given time I do think it's going to
be resurrected in by default that will make
him a very special person in the narrative
but I don't know that will still extra powers
on top of them using the fact that he holds
a Valyrian blade like Camilla Sander were
to say like light it on fire and it glowed
just like Stan this is Blake did whenever
she left it on fire then you could call him
is or high and I don't think any of the other
characters like anywhere in the world would
challenge that they were they would just be
like okay so we heard the story of him being
resurrected by the Lord of light years aflame
blade you must be this mythical figure is
totally okay to be skeptical about that just
because it seems like the obvious choice like
he is an error seem like the obvious choice
to be this mythical figure just because it
seems like there been so many clues that support
that evidence that everyone can is kinda wondering
if it's gonna be some unexpected person that
will be as or high I think the title is exactly
that just a title that can be given to anyone
at any given time the real key is getting
everyone to believe it and it's a lot easier
to do that when you see someone get resurrected
next question Gala frame gamer asks when you
think of the surviving start children like
Sansone are you will reunite and in what circumstance
think Bran will forever be the three had Raven
but surely the star girls will see each other
again while I'm actually I'm kinda hoping
that they don't meet up I do hope that they
learned that each other is alive but I'd I
don't want them to like have a really Modlin
like hug it out moment that's more like a
cynical view but as I I feel like it would
be a little over-the-top if like everybody
got their hearts wish I could turn into fanfiction
you could argue that it's already moved into
fanfiction territory it is that I feel it
be a little bit more believable for aria to
learn that Sansa still live in feel some measure
of relief and then just kind like continue
on with her life somewhere else in a wandering
around the earth being a faceless person in
Sansone kinda did the same thing where she
lived out the rest of her life knowing that
her sister was alive you know but not getting
busier it be like happy and sad at the same
time next question Carlo asks how things would've
been if the nights the veil had united with
the North once again are you to use them you're
talking about Stan's stances Army I do think
that they'll be an alliance with the veil
buys I think it will be somebody else from
the North is putting an army together it is
in makes sense if they're loyal to your house
and they have this giant force in they hate
the people that are currently occupying winter
fell this is really where little fingers probably
gonna shine at a meeting hopefully liking
his storyline kinda seem to trickle off at
the end of last season is holding is that
he's trying to hold the veil like he's trying
to keep control the veil with the same time
playing the Bolton's the crown against each
other and trying to secure the loyalty of
the Tyrell's I should that he's definitely
trying to play the Tyrell's against the crown
but the queen of thorns is just like a little
bit smarter than everyone else so she is very
aware that he is trying to do that but long
answered I'm sure you'll you will definitely
get to see nights of the veil fighting against
Bolton's eventually next question so II want
to mispronounce your name but yet a really
good question yes about the engine start how
did mention stark end of the nights watched
did he commit a crime or did you just want
to join the watch like Jon Snow what is closer
to the second part mention was the youngest
start mail of his generation so he knew the
he was probably never going to inherit winter
fell and just to avoid problems he joined
the nights which is not unheard of for noble
board youngest child to take the black that's
actually the same reason that Mr. Eyman took
the black is because they were so many other
target Aryans they could have inherited the
throne they were the line of succession and
wanted to turn in another bloodbath in an
obviously things were not that dire in house
stark like they they did not hate each other
that much but the idea of honor and duty are
really big things in the Stark family so so
course bench and would think it be an honorable
thing to take the black but I don't think
it was anything like that was Sam Wells family
per sample was pressured to take the black
next question Dean asks why did Ned Stark
never legitimize Jonstone I'm confused will
I think you know a lot of people asked that
question you know why didn't he tell Jon Snow
who his mother was you know why was it such
a big deal but you know Whitey continue to
be a pastor the problem is is that I think
that that was just like a mutual understanding
of the of the people who understood who Jon
Snow's mother was is that it would be better
if no one knew but just assume for the sake
of argument that Jon Snow's parents are regulatory
Gary and Emily on the Stark think about what
that would do to the kingdom if it was found
out that there was a surviving tar Gary and
mail air Patra lineages a really big thing
he would he would immediately have a more
legitimate claim to the throne in the brassy
instead and then on top of that consider how
everyone is slowly finding out that Cersei's
children are not really brassy and submitted
that they definitely do not have a claim to
the throne so I think that anybody who is
at the tower of joy or found out later who
Jon Snow's parents were decided that it would
be safe for further realm and safer for Jon
Snow if no one found out so it's much safer
for everyone to believe that Jon Snow is a
pastor and he's never going to amount to anything
he's gonna take the black and people just
forget about them of course best laid plans
that's definitely not can end up happening
everyone will find out what happened to Jon
Snow eventually everyone will know his name
next question Mr. arias Stark S what are the
chances that Jon Snow and Danny get married
a lot of people want to see that happen it
sounds a little bit like fanfiction so it's
kind of silly I'm kinda hoping that it doesn't
go that route I'd much rather see one of them
sacrificed their lives in the other one be
forced to rebuild the kingdom in the wake
of a war with the white walkers this is one
of those situations where I do kinda feel
like the show might give people the fanfiction
that they're clamoring for for better or for
worse using the fan theories people come up
with a way more interesting than than the
reality of what ends up happening on screen
so you want to see Jon Snow will become the
new nights king and get married to White Walker
bride it it it actually feels like it be more
likely that he is the nurse would team up
and then they would eventually have to rebuild
the kingdom together despite the fact that
Jon Snow will probably never be able to love
anyone else after egret it be like one of
those loveless marriages like Robert Baratheon
and Cersei had but it just ends up being one
of those things is like so far down the road
that I try not to focus about it too much
so so don't get bummed out if you think the
show is again and the way you wanted to amuse
it's years away at this point next question
Aaron asks in arias three chapter storm of
swords page 249 hardcover is very specific
thank you for the reference Psalms going on
the skin through US about a specific prophecy
one on his shoulder perched a drowned crow
with seaweed hanging from his wings so that
getting in the super spoilers that actually
leads up into what's going on with the Kingsmoot
and it seems that will get like a small version
of that next season shows probably can end
up cutting out a lot of the iron born character
so I don't know how to modify their pride
is can oversimplify the king's boot expected
to go exactly like it does in the books if
you have read the books if you haven't read
the books than then don't worry but seaweed
drowned crow's swing bridge it's all about
balance great joy next question Matt asks
what does little finger me when he tells a
letter Tyrell that he has a gift for her so
if you're talking about during season five
he was just talking about providing him with
the person that could inform on Queen Cersei
that of course we know now is Lance Alanna
stirred the thing is is that Lancelot might
not have known about Cersei's children that
she had with Jamie but he definitely knew
the he slept with her that by itself is a
really big crime in the eyes of the church
anyway so that would've been enough to get
her and really big trouble with the faith
next question Lilo asks if Robb did in the
name Jon's nose there with little finger in
some way or another find out what this is
this is the problem with little finger's character
is that it's hard to tell how smart he is
in the books compared to how smart he is on
the TV show is a apparently he didn't know
anything about Ramsey's know being a complete
psychopath when he married Sansa to him that
he didn't know about Ramsey's and how to get
to find out about a mysterious letter and
I think that he's heard things in it sounds
like he has an idea of what happened between
radar tar Gary and Iliana start so that you
know he does have information is very important
but without actually reading him talking about
it in the books or seeing him talk about it
on the show it is complete subtext this point
I think that he would find out about Robb
Stark legitimizing Jon snow I mean if it did
happen he would find out about it with everyone
else he interviewed pry be just as surprised
as anyone else to find out about that but
thank you so much everyone for something questions
big stuff happening tonight the flash is coming
back and then arrows coming back tomorrow
is the shield is also tonight to So i'll explain
my schedule and stole a bit but they just
released the duck in a book so that is what
the giveaway is for now argillaceous the first
book giveaway winner Darth Zana you and a
copy of knight of the seven kingdoms and get
you the Kindle the paperback anything you
want just be sure to private message me on
the back and my channels and your contact
info gonna happen now is the just like the
next couple weeks I'm just going to be giving
way copies of the book that's of the giveaway
will be for so be sure to subscribe to get
everything actually someone actually asked
me for it Ashara Dayne bonus video I might
actually do that next I don't think that I've
done a video for her specifically yet I've
done and Arthur Danye videos all put a link
that in the description if you guys haven't
been watching the flash you need to start
now to be awesome I think it's sitting Netflix
tonight to subunits in season one you can
totally catch up way way for it to come you
can click here to watch all my flash trailer
videos and you can click here to learn all
about Arthur Danye in the books thank you
so much watching everybody let's high five
I will totally see you in a couple hours